because he killed a lot of people over
the years
and got away with all of it until
finally at the end um
it all caught up with him there's
obviously a difference though right i
mean he
he was doing it it was very intertwined
in his business
and it wasn't just out of pure enjoyment
he was
killing people you know he did he didn't
get some sort of dopamine rush from
murdering people he was doing it because
he
he had to well there was one where he
whacked a guy in a hotel room who was
late on a
there was a cocaine shipment was late
and the guy give the money to
um two tony's been up all night on coke
and he's getting more and more pissed
off on him and he goes into the guy's
room
or the guy came into his room i can't
remember what it was
and the guy said something disrespectful
and
two tony just blew his brains out so
i wouldn't say it was the smartest thing
to do from a business perspective
yeah risk yourself you know in a death
penalty state
over such a small but when you're on
coke
and you're feeling disrespected and your
ego is pumped up like that
then you know you're just whacking
people for trivial reasons
right if you're a psychopath and he said
he was a psychopath
he said that he was yeah
now where he passed away right
even as he was an old man before he
passed away he spent the day fantasizing
about smashing sex offenders
teeth in with crowbars and things like
that
[Music]
now what was it like leading up to your
release finally
in prison oh the release
it was um happy because
you know the first year since of
incarceration seems to last forever
and then it kind of like
goes starts going faster and faster and
faster
and by the end of it it's going really
fast
and they say that going into prison
really messes your head but soda's
coming out
and in this country they call it gay
fever right
so you're thinking you know am i going
to get a girlfriend
you're scared right you have lots of
fear will i uh will people cross the
road to avoid me i've been in prison now
how can i get a job so all these fears
are in your in your head but i was
blessed to have such good family
my mom my dad my sister and um
so my release story is
i've got this release that this lawyer
that the new mexican mafia
the the lawyers got me this release date
and the release date comes but they
don't release me so i'm thinking oh
they've made some kind of mistake
it was a few days later they did finally
release me
i had this thing called a half-time
release for a non-us
uh citizen that this kind of loophole
lawyer got me
and i was thinking has it been processed
processed so i'm all worried you know
i'm not going to get out and
do more more years but in the end i got
this it came down
the feds came to get me to take me to
the federal
deportation prison i can't remember is
it florence mirana
somewhere in arizona it's been so long
now
so i'm in this federal deportation
prison which of course is
all mexicans and one guy from england
and i picked up a bit of spanish by then
so i'm talking to them
you know some of them can't speak
english so they're asking me to ask the
guards certain things
so i'm making myself useful with the
mexican community
and they can't give you
the date of your exact release for
security reasons
so eventually they come and say roll up
outward you know
your release is is come and um
they put us all on a conor flight
con air have you seen connor yes only
my favorite movie in the world so me and
all the mexicans are shackled in this
but on this prison ball so that's good
to hear
there's no aircon on it's the snow is it
is the plane just like the plane and con
air
what happens is it's all federal
marshals
they're looking at you there's like rows
of federal marshals and rows of
prisoners
and you're all shackled you can't go up
and have a pee or anything
and if you try anything funny they look
like they're gonna shoot you
so we all get on no first off they leave
us on the bus for ages and we're all up
near suffocating in in the desert
then they put us on the plane but then
they say the plane is broke down
and we gotta go back to the jail and
come back the next day
so there's all this this this pallava
eventually the plane
takes off and um for a couple of days
then i'm on connor
going across arizona and california
dropping off
and picking up mexicans it's like they
make work for themselves just flying
these planes around
wow they they arrest mexicans and they
drop them off at a different part of the
border
where they arrested them in the hope
that you know that's going to
cause them not to come back in it's so
it's all crap it's all again government
financed [ __ ] at the taxpayers
expense so i get to la
and um
[Music]
i'm in a holding cell then in la
and it's going all through the night and
i'm so excited i'm getting out i can't
sleep but i'm so tired as well
my head's like nodding and stuff was sat
there there's no seats or anything
just crouched against the wall and you
know and um
there's there was a guy in there who'd
been in the news
he'd crashed a
some kind of car i don't know it was a
ferrari or what it was
a couple hundred grand i think this car
he crashed this car at 160 miles an hour
jesus so ridiculous i don't know what
he'd been doing
but this this like european gangster
i can't remember his name i've written
it all in my book prison time if you
want to
check that out my trilogy is on amazon
as well it's um
party time hard time prison time prison
time details my release
and um so i'm talking to him he's quite
cool he's like yeah i got a place in
london come and come and see me in
london all this stuff
and i have looked since he is a proper
full-on gangs he's got like a wiki page
and i think he's back in prison now
um so i'm talking to him he's been on
the news so he's kind of like a bit of a
celebrity in the
with his record crash and
everyone just gets really quiet as the
night progresses you know like two three
in the morning
except for some guy
from was he from brazil
no argentina argentina and this guy
is like hyper i don't know if he's on
coke or crystal meth
so everyone's falling asleep and not
trying to fall asleep but they can't
because this guy's just
telling all these stories he's like yeah
my woman is a supermodel
and she's flown all the way to argentina
she's waiting for me we're gonna get
married
and she's so kind she stops for homeless
people
and she wakes me up every day every
single day with a [ __ ]
this guy's just going oh no no
i'm having you know even this guy's
bragging oh he's insane
what the [ __ ] but he's going on and on
and on and nobody can sleep
and one minute i'm just sat in the car
trying to sleep i'm next minute i'm like
i [ __ ]
i just walk over started listening to
him i'm losing my mind as well
you're trying to occupy my time i don't
know what i'm doing so after days of
this
this is what it's like nothing happens
in the hurry yeah
days of this the um
[Music]
a guard comes and says look i'm taking
some of you to the airport
and he calls out me and the argentinian
so we leave the jail in this
this prison boss prison fan we're all
shackled up
we've got one guy i think there's just
one guard in there federal federal
driver
and um you know what the traffic's like
in la it is
bumper to bumper so we are
we are just stuck all the way
and the driver goes
if we don't get there this is all gonna
have to be rescheduled
now i'm thinking rescheduled means we
just get on the next flight you know we
can't go on this flight we just go on
the next flight
and the argentinian he's he's just
he's he's been hyper still still
tweaking
still tweaking all of a sudden his face
just goes to sheer panic it's like
rescheduled
rescheduled i'm like yeah no problem
we're just going to get rescheduled
no don't you know what rescheduled means
he goes that means we have to go back to
our original
you know some federal deportation prison
and the whole thing and it takes weeks
or months
to reschedule to get on another flight
so he explains this and i'm like oh my
[ __ ] god you know my parents are on
the way to london to meet with the
airport
so we get to um no
he brings us back to the jail
and um because we're getting rescheduled
and the argentinians
right now the argentinian right now has
just lost his mind
he's walking we're both walking to the
jail the argentinian starts going
can i have a cigarette can i smoke can
someone give me a cigarette
and of course no one's going to give him
a [ __ ] cigarette he's a convict
in chair in chains right she starts
going crazy i need a cigarette
and they end up just putting him in a
room he's just like rocking like this
he's just
that's it he's he's completely done
now what kind of [ __ ] did he have to
smoke to last that long
i have no idea but i'm feeling for him
you know he's saying his supermodel
girlfriend's waiting for him to marry
him
wow so um
whatever he was full of [ __ ] or not you
know it would have been nice if things
have got out and have a life
you